hey marker chat here we go and
action the queen of souls
i was looking the word up genius an
exceptional quality
so of course aretha franklin has an
exceptional quality she has her
beautiful voice
her amazing and brilliant piano playing
and she's the first
american in the series the first woman
the first person of color and she was
able to
alchemize her life into sonic gold my
singing voice has always been my
guardian angel
keeps me safe
it feels good to share with the world
that
black women contain genius that we are
geniuses
i need y'all to follow me because we're
gonna get lost otherwise cynthia arrivo
is just phenomenal it blows me away to
hear
how much she sounds like aretha and how
she embodies her
as just a fan of aretha i've listened to
her music since i was little
and i was learning her music before i
knew i was going to be doing anything
like this
we gonna look good we gonna feel good
yes
this is a big show we have a lot of
costume changes
a lot of the pieces that i've done also
replicates what she actually wore at
certain events that we want to honor
in series
[Music]
thank you so much thank you very much
we're allowing the audience access to
what it was like for her back then and
there was a lot of
stress and trauma and you learn those
things and you just go
how did she become aretha franklin as we
know her
the idea that she was able to combine
her music
with activism is really special and i
don't know that people realize that she
was an activist
they shoot us down like dogs like our
lives ain't worth nothing it's time to
make a stand
people forget how powerful music can be
considered
and she used that power to empower the
rest of her community
you got to disturb the piece when you
can't get no peace
that's why we celebrate her she's the
queen of soul
your soul mine everybody's she earned
that crown
[Music]
you